Google you know we've talked a lot about
Google glass but even before most people
are on the Google glass Google contact
lenses are on the way we've got an image
how it works the Google contact lens
contains a control circuit an image
capture camera component and an image
sensor it can be wirelessly linked to a
mobile phone for data access and to
issue commands via audio the system will
be able to detect faces potentially
allowing the blind to recognize people
okay so there's a lot of good stuff the
medical stuff helping the blind
obviously great so we've talked a lot
about Google glass here and I firm
believer it's gonna completely change
how we all act if your glasses right now
because they already have that it's
going to be able to be put in designer
glasses you're gonna be able to be
recording let's imagine if I felt like I
was still gonna have to have them
recording one of them yeah I know that
would be very that would be terrible but
it seems like we're already skipping
ahead like we're gonna have Google glass
for like a couple months yeah and you
know some people have it already but
we're gonna have it for a couple months
and then bang it's gonna be in contact
lenses is this scary people I always say
well Gabe you're against science when I
when I do this you're against technology
because I don't want to be recorded at
every second what do you think I split
on this because at first I'm like oh
this is super like Logan's Run and then
they're gonna like pop my eyeball out
when I get to a certain age it's gonna
be horrible
yeah it's like it's too late seriously
go [ __ ] yourself like you think about
like cochlear implants and all this
stuff that makes deaf people be able to
hear and if this is that if this if this
can be that for blind people they're
talking about I don't know I didn't
realize so many people are having
diabetes problems with diabetes but yeah
they said that to regulate their glucose
is gonna be really helpful that's cool
but is that what this is really about I
doubt it right somehow this will really
be about porn yeah that's how it all
goes that porn leads the way with
technology I don't I'm not sold on
Google glass I've been wrong on a lot of
stuff I think it until I see something
that indicated people want to distort
their faces and right now it's a facial
distortion yeah oh the way the laserdisc
it might I mean some it's not like we've
had like it'll work and something but
walking around having to touch your
glasses like there's gonna come a point
where
where it's too it's too upsetting into
our regular lives right and right now
Google glass looks like it I get it
there's gonna be some cool component
there might be some time that you want
to do it yeah well it wasn't kidding and
they're gonna they're already making
designer glasses they are not as
obtrusive no but it still you still
still have to have the camera right
people who are wearing Google glasses
want you to know the reticle class right
so we're reading the story on it and
like in paragraph nine what it was
included in your list there Dave is like
a muscle might also help the contact
lens might also help the blind see and
I'm like they really buried that lead I
would have led with that I want to open
was weeding your blindness yeah that's
more important yeah maybe
Wow no that's the thing yeah that
actually was second to glue coat coat
checking your glucose yeah yeah that's
what that's what they were invented for
to read the glucose for diabetics so
they can constantly monitor what you
meant because it can be read in the
fascinating alright so I think what
you're both saying is I should stop
being so fearful of where this all leads
or I've just watched so many science
fiction movies and smoke so much time
that I always see everything where the
robots come get us I don't doubt that at
all yeah you've done that yeah here's
the thing look if I'm holding my phone
yeah I'm probably recording you so it's
like what just as a public service to
you yeah but that's the thing it's like
you say I don't want to be recorded I
don't want it you know it's making you
paranoid but we're already being
recorded all the time whether you like
it or not whether you know it or not so
how is the cloud how are the glass is
any different yeah do you think we're
gonna have places ultimately I think
they've been popping up already I think
there's a bar in Portland where people
are they're banning Google glass but do
you think we're gonna have like
technology free zones like where you're
gonna go to dinner and they're not
they're gonna literally take your phone
about yeah yeah there already are some
those place tonight when I went to work
a little office place I mean it's not
technology freak with everybody there's
working on their screenplay computers
yeah but I mean you can't talk on the
phone you can't there can't be any noise
and I think there'll be more of that I
just like 3d glasses like 3d TVs and
maybe that will take over but in the
moment that you make people watch
television or watch a movie and force
them to put heavy glasses on first them
to put something on their face I just
think it's different I'm not I'm
prepared to be wrong but my hunch is
that something will get in the way yeah
well that's just the small step before
the
the contact lenses and then that may
that may be the proof that but also
touch their eye I mean I know there's a
lot of contact lens wearers but Jesus
how do you people do that because I've
never seen you have you ever won
contests yeah one for years I don't wear
em to play you know what I've said to be
an athlete
[Music]